Wladimir Klitschko gegen Dieter Bohlen
das ist kein Box Duell das ist nicht der
neue DSDS soft sondern das ist ein ganz
ernsthafter Streit über den Ukraine
Krieg und die Russland Sanktionen die
beiden top Promis die streiten über
unseren Umgang mit Putin genauso wie
Millionen Deutsche dass derzeit in ihrem
Alltag tun und Auslöser ist dieser
Auftritt hier von Dieter Bohlen bei
einem Unternehmer Event wo er plötzlich
über die deutschen Russland Sanktionen
herzieht
aber ich bin eben der Meinung
wir sind ihr könnt mich ruhig ausruhen
ja aber wenn die diese Sanktionen zum
Beispiel nicht gemacht hätten und man
hätte sich vernünftig an einen Tisch
gesetzt ja dann bräuchten die Leute sich
jetzt nicht den ganzen völlefanz machen
ja die Leute jetzt müssen wir frieren
jetzt müssen wir dies und das das ist
doch alles scheiße von von aus meiner
Sicht ja man kann das jetzt sehen okay
mit dem kriechen Ukraine man kann das
immer alles aber ich meine alles was da
so passiert und das Russland jetzt für
viel viel mehr Geld Gast nach Asien
verkauft und das ist ja ich meine das
verstehe ich alles nicht mehr ja Dieter
Bohlen der sie nicht versteht die
Russland Sanktionen und ukraines
Boxweltmeister Wladimir Klitschko der
sich Bohnen jetzt dafür vorknöpft klickt
sagt genau das zu Dieter Büro in ich
höre und lese hier das gerade in
Deutschland immer wieder die Sanktionen
gegen Russland in Frage gestellt werden
wie kann das sein dann fragt der Dieter
Bohlen direkt ist dir das egal wenn bei
uns Menschen sterben und weiter
Klitschko dann ist Dir Dieter Bohlen
egal das Putin unser Land mit Raketen
zerstören will ist dir egal dass wir
einen Genozid gegen alles ukrainische
erleben ja die wirtschaftlich Situation
die es für viele Menschen derzeit eine
große Herausforderung auch in
Deutschland aber eben er wendet sich
direkt an Dieter Bohlen das ist ein Satz
von Klitschko wie ein k.o für Dieter
Bohlen der die Sanktionen gegen Russland
und Putin nicht versteht Bildreporter
Paul Ronzheimer dazu jetzt in der
Ukraine grüße Dich guten Morgen Paul
Klitschko ärgert sich richtig über
bowlen
ja Klitschko ist richtig sauer ich habe
gestern Nacht noch mit ihm telefoniert
darüber auch über dieses Video und ja
ist da sehr emotional geworden denn
Wladimir Klitschko gehört zu dem die am
Montag als City Raketen reinkam nach
Kiew als das Zentrum angegriffen wurde
nicht weit entfernt war das ist auch
sein Arbeitsweg den er mit dem Auto
nimmt auch er hätte da getroffen werden
können und wenn man das aus dieser
Perspektive betrachtet aus einer Stadt
die gerade erst angegriffen wurde und
wenn man dann sowas hört von Dieter
Bohlen den er auch persönlich kennt aus
der vergangenen Zeit vor 20 Jahren gab
es man gemeinsam wenn das Auftritt zum
Beispiel man kennt sich als super Promi
und jetzt würde ich sagen vielleicht
willst du dich Dieter Bohlen noch nicht
mit Wladimir Klitschko vergleichen aber
was den Bekanntheitsgrad angeht eben in
Deutschland und natürlich ist es etwas
was man immer wieder hört und das
spricht er auch an dort im in seiner
Nachricht wir erleben die Proteste wir
erleben die Debatten in Deutschland dazu
und er sagt ganz klar wie könnt ihr das
in so einer Phase in Frage stellen in
dem Fall wie kann Dieter Bohlen das in
so einer Phase in Frage stellen denn
eins ist ja ganz klar
Dieter Bohlen tut in diesem Statement so
als hätte man sich irgendwie an einem
Tisch setzen können und das anders lösen
können die Wahrheit ist Wladimir Putin
hatte nein Marsch befohlen Wladimir
Putin ähm hat der Ukraine das
Existenzrecht abgesprochen und Vladimir
Putin
ist dafür verantwortlich dass sie 10.000
Menschen gestorben sind gleichzeitig wir
sind gerade noch mal diesen Auftritt von
Dieter Bohlen es gab reichlich Applaus
dort ja auch in dem Publikum also er
spricht das aus Dieter Bohlen und kriegt
dafür dann auch noch Beifall relativ
viel sogar die beiden kennen sich hast
du gerade gesagt Wladimir Klitschko und
Dieter Bohlen hättest du das für möglich
weil das persönliche Erleben ja so oft
auch hilft in der Ukraine dass er den
Bohlen einlädt nach Kiew
ich habe wlademy Klitschko und Vitali
Klitschko immer so erlebt dass sie immer
bereit waren zu zeigen was sie wirklich
passiert ist ob sie dafür Zeit haben
jetzt Dieter Bohlen hier durch Kiew zu
führen in dieser Situation das weiß ich
nicht aber ganz generell stehen die
beiden sehr transparent für Aufklärung
geben viele Interviews zeigen immer
wieder was hier vor Ort passiert wennten
sich direkt an Deutschland treten in
Deutschland auf Wladimir Klitschko war
zuletzt in Potsdam zum Beispiel er hat
dort eine Rede gehalten vor dem
Bundeskanzler und darauf gedrungen noch
schärfere Sanktionen vorzunehmen da ging
es unter anderem um die Einreise von
Russen aber auch die Frage eben der
wirtschaftlichen Sanktionen denn das ist
das entscheidende hier aus seiner
Perspektive aus der politischen
Perspektive in der Ukraine oder
halbpolitischen im Fall von Wladimir
Klitschko dass sie sagen es ist eben
nicht nur Putin sondern Russland da sind
russische Soldaten 10.000 die hier
reinkommen und damit dieser Krieg ein
Ende hat braucht es ein Aufbäumen gegen
Putin und ein Aufbäumen gegen diesen
Krieg und das kann aus seiner Sicht aus
der Sicht vieler Politiker hier in der
Ukraine nur gelingen wenn man harte
Sanktionen fährt Klitschko gegen Dieter
Bohlen also genau wie die beiden jetzt
öffentlich streiten so wird die
Diskussion hier in Deutschland jeden Tag
im Alltag geführt unter Millionen
Deutschen
[Musik]